all right one more clip this is the last
one from the turning point usa event to
try to indoctrinate young people into
right-wing reactionary thinking this is
republican congressman matt gates he has
an idea he says that the only women who
are in favor of abortion being a choice
are the women who would never need an
abortion because they're too ugly for
anyone to impregnate them to begin with
which is an interesting interesting
theory for him to be making take a
listen to this have you watched these
pro-abortion pro-murder rallies the
people
are just disgusting
like why is it
that
the women with the least likelihood of
getting pregnant are the ones most
worried about having abortions
nobody wants to impregnate you if you
look like a thumb
these people are odious on the inside
and out they're like 5-2
350 pounds and they're like give me my
abortions or i'll get up in march and
protest and i'm thinking march
you look like you got ankles weaker than
the legal reasoning behind roe versus
wade
a few of them need to get up in march
they need to get up and march for like
an hour a day swing those arms get the
blood pumping maybe mix in a salad now
as absurd as this is if it were true
there would be no demand for abortion
services right i mean like it's a it's
so stupid and of course it you know
it's fat phobic it's it's it's
misogynistic it's everything if only
women who no one would have sex with
want abortions there would by definition
be no abortion so it's by definition not
true
and even after
this tirade after this disgusting tirade
from a disgusting guy
women will still vote for him like it's
crazy but he will almost certainly be
re-elected and so as a reminder when you
hear the things that matt gates says and
we say that is just vile how how does
someone like this get elected it's
really horrible that he exists no no
he's not the disease he's the symptom
the disease is the people in
i forget what he represents is it the
pensacola area or whatever in florida
the the disease is
that people will vote for him despite
these comments or even because of
comments like this just a dis completely
disgusting guy and this is
sort of the new wave of republicanism i
am not
pre now
now that we've seen what took place at
this turning point usa event over the
weekend i'm not saying that i
am a supporter of the politics of the
sort of cadre of
mitt romney
john mccain
george w bush dick cheney like i'm not a
supporter of that but there is sort of a
battle for the republican party right
now where you have on the one hand
people like in the modern day
romney and liz cheney and to a lesser
degree adam kinzinger or whoever that's
one side
and then on the other side you have
bobert green
trump
gates
those types of people
and there's no real way to know right
now
what the republican party will look like
in five years and i used the number five
specifically that would be 2027 it would
be after these midterms and the next
presidential and one more midterm that's
three election cycles what will the
republican party look like in five years
is it going to be more like the bush
romney mccain republican party
is it going to be an even exponentially
more cuckoo for cocoa puffs version of
the trumpian republican party is it
going to be a new thing altogether will
it split we don't know but when you look
at an event like turning point usa
there's none of that other type of
conservatism there there's no
conservatism at all this is really just
ignorant reactionary thinking um i don't
know what it's going to look like in
five years but it's going to be a
hellish path for the united states no
matter which way it goes many people are
shocked when their identity is stolen
but it's actually one of the fastest
growing crimes in the u.s i've dealt
with it it's a terrible feeling and
that's why i now protect myself with
aura one of our sponsors aura monitors
email addresses passwords social
security number bank accounts credit
cards and i can set it up to instantly
get an alert on my phone if something
happens and then aura goes through the
process of fixing it as well aura also
does things like make sure no one's
opening up bank accounts or credit cards
in your name or it takes all the tools
you need to protect all of your accounts
and devices puts them in one easy app
identity theft protection fraud
monitoring password management antivirus
all in one place at aura.com pacman you
can try aura free for two weeks you can
do things like check whether your login
credentials have been leaked the whole
world might know your email password
right now and you can find out for free
i found an old password in four
different data breaches the link is down
below